all right time for this week's
sin city chronicles a weekly look back
the vegas history and happenings and
let's start with the arrival of the king
elvis presley first performed in las
vegas at the new frontier on april 23rd
1956 the 21 year old
was paid 15 000 for a two-week stint
now the show was considered a flop
because the regular crowd of middle-aged
adults had no idea who he was
it would be 13 years later when elvis
eventually returned
to las vegas the desert inn opened on
april 24th
1950 it was a two-day opening event and
it was headlined by abbott and costello
now when builder wilbur clark this is so
cool open the doors
he tossed away the keys to the main
entrance and proclaimed
there would never be a need to lock them
again the doors
they never closed until the property
closed 50 years later
the riviera hotel opened on april 20th
1955
at nine stories it was the first
high-rise on the strip i love these
photos
liberace cut the opening ribbon and
became the first resident performer
now the hotel it actually had a
connection to the rat pack dean martin
was a minority owner
[Music]
[Applause]
he-man was one of the biggest cartoons
of the 1980s
and in april 1987 the masters of the
universe touring show
came to the thomas and mack for five
nights and all
five nights were sold out the crowd was
treated to appearances by he-man
she-ra and of course skeletor
[Music]
last week we talked about u2's first
vegas concert well 10 years later april
25th
1997 the band kicked off their pop mark
tour at sam boyd stadium
37 000 fans were on hand including
celebrities christian slater winona
ryder robert de niro and
rem the show was featured on an abc
special
and if you wanted to meet the band when
they were in town they were staying at
the luxor they actually had the top four
floors all to themselves
and that's your sin city chronicles for
the third week of april las vegas now
we'll be right back